on
le mirage 2000 est le successeur du
mirage iii dont il possède plusieurs
caractéristiques telles que la voilure
delta et la configuration mono réacteurs
c'est en 1973 que commence le programme
du mirage 2000
sur demande du gouvernement ce tout
nouvel avion devait être capable de
voler entre mac 2,45 mg ac3 un plafond
conflit entre 22700 et 24 1400 mètres
d'altitude
le 10 mai 1976 a lieu le premier vol du
mirage 2000
le mirage 2000 connaît un succès
important est présente à ce jour
plusieurs versions y compris les
biplaces d'entraînement c'est un
chasseur d'interception et de
supériorité aérienne largement distribué
à l'étranger
le mirage 2000 a succédé au mirage 3 e à
dijon et au mirage f1 à orange et à
cambrai le mirage 2000 s'est fait son
entrée en service en 1984 il est destiné
à remplacer le mirage f1 dans les
missions de défense aérienne
ce nouveau chasseur français apporte à
l'époque une véritable évolution pour
l'armée de l'air
nouvelle voilure matériaux modernes
moteur m53 développé par la snecma
commandes de vol électriques
le mirage 2000 ouvrages aux pilotes
alliés qui viendront s'y frotter au
cours d'exercices qu'il n'a plus rien à
voir avec son prédécesseur le mirage iii
le mirage 2000c porte les couleurs du
camouflage bicolore standard de l'armée
de l'air il grippale et bleu c'est un
chasseur monoplace multirôle
intercepteurs tout temps et chasseurs de
supériorité aérienne qui est la pièce
maîtresse des forces aériennes
françaises conventionnelle et stratégie
le mirage 2000 c est doté d'un turbo
réacteurs monocorps double flux snecma
m50 3-5 et son évolution m 53 p 2
développant une poussée de 9 tonnes 5
avec post combustion
l'excellent comportement aérodynamique
de la voiture delta autorise une vitesse
maximale de mach 2.3 avec une vitesse
ascensionnelle maximale de 17 mm minutes
pour un plafond d'opérations de 18 mm
d'une envergure de 9 mai 2013 pour une
longueur de 14 mètres 60
le mirage 2000n passe d'une masse à vide
de 9,26 à une masse au décollage de ses
stocks
le mirage 2000c du début a très
rapidement été améliorée grâce à la
version du moteur aim 53 p 2 et surtout
du nouveau radar rdi de thomson
remplaçant le radar rdm du début son
armement principal est constitué de deux
canons de 30 mm à provisionner chacun
225 connu de deux missiles matra magique
550 à guidage infrarouge pour le combat
rapproché et de deux matra super 530d à
guidage électromagnétiques pour le tir à
moyenne portée
les mirage 2000c tous en version erdei
qui équipe aujourd'hui quatre escadrons
ont été engagés dans la première guerre
du golfe et dans les opérations
aériennes au dessus de l'ex yougoslavie
l'évolution la plus récente du mirage
2000c à radar rdi le mirage 2000-5 f&a
radar multicibles air d y apporte depuis
quelques années à l'armée de l'air un
avant-goût du rafale
je vous présente le mirage 2000d qui
équipent donc l'escadron de chasse 2 3
champagne qui est un biplace de
pénétration haute et moyenne altitude et
basse attitude aussi disposant d'une
gamme d'armement variés cette gamme
d'armement va des bombes guidées laser
donc gbu-12 âgé de 24 ans passant par
les missiles de croisière opérationnel
pour le moment le missile apache et
bientôt le missile scalp ainsi de
l'armement air-air mais si le magic 2
qui va permettre de s'auto défendre
d'assurer sa protection face à
d'éventuels interception aérienne
le mirage 2000d étant un biplace
opérationnel donc avec un pilote et un
officier système d'armes va permettre de
réaliser des missions complexes de
pénétration basse moyenne altitude au
profit des troupes au sol de nuit comme
de jour
et quelles que soient les conditions
météorologiques ces missions pour être
des missions d'attaqué
grâce à des munitions guidées laser de
type gbu-12 ou gpu 24 ou des missions
que nous appelons close air support tu
d'appui au sol d'appui des troupes au
sol grâce aux capteurs dont on va
disposer et notamment aux nacelles de
désignation de type edel cts ou à clis
le mirage 2000d bénéficie d'un système
de protection électronique est
complètement intégrée qui va permettre à
l'avion grâce à un certain nombre
d'antennes répartis tout autour de la
structure de détecter les menaces
électromagnétiques l'environnement
électromagnétique dans lequel évolue
l'avion d'analyser ces menaces
éventuellement de reconnaître quel type
de menaces il s'agit de présenter cette
situation à l'équipage donc aux pilotes
et aux navigateurs de façon à ce que
celui ci puisse prendre les mesures
adéquates notamment l'utilisation de
leurres infrarouges de paillettes
électromagnétiques
et puis bien sûr le brouillage
électromagnétiques qui va consister à
rey et m
des émissions électromagnétiques de
façon à perturber la poursuite la
détection et la poursuite de l'avion par
les systèmes solaires adverse
cette carapace électronique sur le 2010
est particulièrement performante et nous
permet de réaliser les missions
opérationnelles en général en étant bien
protégée par rapport aux menaces solaire
et rr qui sont présentes dans ses
différentes missions
le mirage 2000d et le premier chasseur
bombardier véritablement tout temps que
possède l'armée
à peine entré en service le mirage 2000d
a été envoyé au combat dans le cadre de
l'opération crécerelle au dessus de la
bosnie herzégovine
puis il a été de tous les déploiements
de l'armée de l'air depuis l'afghanistan
jusqu'au congo en passant par le kosovo
le mirage 2000d au standard r2 peut
tirer l'ensemble des armements
conventionnels mis en oeuvre par l'armée
de l'air armement guidée laser missiles
de croisière air-sol et autres munitions
guidées de précision tirer à distance de
sécurité la nacelle et sous l'avion
le pilote va choisir sa cible il va
éclairer la cible avec le faisceau laser
la bombe à venir seule idée sur le
faisceau pour frapper sa cible c'est ce
qu'on appelle la frappe chirurgicale à
l'atelier optronique de nancy ochey nous
traitons les potes de désignation laser
qui sont montés sous différents avions
le mirage 2000d qui est sûrement c'est
le jaguar qui est basée à saint dizier
elle est super étendard modernisés de la
marine nationale qui sont embarqués sur
le porte avions charles de gaulle
donc les modes de désignation laser se
décompose en trois parties une partie
électronique une partie climatisation et
une partie optiques à l'avant de la
nacelle qui sera traité dans une salle
spéciale une salle blanche qui est sans
poussière dans cette partie optique on
va pouvoir s'occuper de
l'émetteur-récepteur laser de la tête tv
de la caméra vidéo en fait qui va filmer
la cie
émission récente réalisée par le mirage
2000d son participation à la campagne au
kosovo plus récemment encore
participation en afghanistan aux
missions contre le terrorisme
international et notamment contre les
installations des talibans en
afghanistan
l'occasion de participer à ces missions
qui sont relativement complexes et
difficiles surtout assez long puisqu'il
s'agissait de vols d'une durée pouvant
aller jusqu'à 7 heures avec cinq
ravitaillements en vol
le mirage 2000n haine pour nucléaire a
remplacé le mirage iv dans les missions
de bombardement nucléaire
à l'image de son fameux prédécesseur il
a été doté d'un poste de pilotage
biplace dans lequel à un pilote et un
navigateur officier système d'armes
prennent place pour affronter avec
succès des missions de plus en plus
complexes et ce par tous les pores
aujourd'hui 60 appareils sont
disponibles au sein de trois escadrons
des forces aériennes stratégiques
il met en oeuvre principalement le
missile asmpa air-sol moyenne portée de
frappe nucléaire mais peuvent aussi
tirer des bombes conventionnelles si
nécessaire
bien entendu sa capacité à ravitailler
en vol fait du mirage 2000n un avion
apte à remplir des missions de longue
durée voire de très longue durée
la première action de guerre dans
laquelle il fut engagé a eu lieu en 1994
les appareils fournis par les faces
forces aériennes stratégiques opérés
depuis servia en italie et larguer des
bombes guidées mk82 de 250 kg sur les
forces serbes
malgré une quinzaine d'années d'activité
le mirage 2000n reste un avion au fort
potentiel d'évolution pour exploiter ce
potentiel l'éventail des missions sera
élargie dans un avenir proche avec la
création d'un standard k3 les appareils
portés à ce niveau pourront mettre en
oeuvre le nouveau missile asmpa et la
nacelle de reconnaissance de nouvelle
génération pour à terme remplacer le
mirage f1 cr
le mirage 2000-5 est un chasseur 100%
français auquel tous les grands
équipementiers ont apporté leur savoir
faire
depuis le radar r d y de thales qui
permet le tir multi cibles et simultanée
de quatre missiles mica jusqu'au train
d'atterrissage signé messier dowty le
mirage 2000-5 offre à la france une
totale indépendance en matière d'avions
en 1993 l'armée de l'air décide de
porter à 37 le nombre des mirage 2000
s'est modifiée en version 2000-5 celui
ci est pratiquement un nouvel avion
bien qu'il soit très difficile de le
distinguer visuellement de son
prédécesseur l'armée de l'air reçoit
avec le 2000-5 son premier avion à
capacité de tir multi cibles
celle ci est articulé autour du missile
mica à guidage électromagnétiques et du
radar r d y
la révolution a lieu également dans le
cockpit ou l'instrumentation
traditionnel électromécanique et
remplacé par un ensemble de cinq écrans
couleur multifonction
comme on le voit sur ce simulateur ce
concept moderne repose sur le principe
des 3èmes main sur manche et manette ce
qui permet au pilote non seulement de
piloter mais également de gérer les
systèmes essentiels de son avion sans
jamais lâcher les commandes devant
lancé sur fonds propres par dassault
thales et snecma l'initiative de
développer le 2000-5 aura donné
naissance à un avion véritablement
moderne aux capacités accrues
électronique moderniser autonomie accrue
grâce à trois réservoirs largable pour
un total de 9000 litres capacité
d'emport de munitions élevé le 2000-5
est taillé pour l'émission de
supériorité aérienne dans lesquelles il
excelle et s'intègre parfaitement dans
le concept d'une europe de défense
romani très diverses d'ailleurs le
mirage 2000 toutes versions confondues
peut mettre en oeuvre un nombre
impressionnant d'armement
un mirage de la base d'orange se voit
équipée du missile matra super 530d
cet avion peut emporter deux exemplaires
de ce missile à guidage
électromagnétiques encore employé sur
les mirage 2000 c
son armement est complété par deux
missiles magique 2a à guidage infrarouge
pour le combat rapproché
sur ces images du cea m de
mont-de-marsan un mirage f1 va tester un
nouveau lens bombe de la société riffaud
cet appareil est équipé de gpu ou bombes
guidées par faisceau laser les gbu-12 et
24 selon les modèles permettent de
détruire des cibles diverses au sol
allant du simple hangar au bâtiment à
structure durci
ces bombes sont guidés par un faisceau
laser émis par l'avion
ou dans certains cas par des troupes au
sol
l'apache armes propulsé à charge
éjectable est un missile de croisière
air-sol destiné à l'attack des piste
d'aérodrome il intègre un système de
navigation lui permettant d'effectuer un
vol subsonic à très basse altitude et
avec une précision d'impact de l'ordre
de 15 m le scalp système de croisière
autonome à longue portée est un missile
de croisière air-sol destiné à l'attack
d'objectifs durcie après un vol subsonic
en suivi de terrain
la précision est assurée par une
imagerie infrarouge
l'ice 30
ici sur un jaguar de la base de
saint-dizier et est un missile air-sol
supersonique autopropulsés en
autorotation est piloté par intercepteur
de ger il est prêt guidé dans sa phase
initiale et autoguidés sur une tache
laser dans la phase finale de son vol
la smp missiles air-sol moyenne portée à
tête nucléaire fait l'objet d'une
procédure particulière et très précise
pour son installation sous l'avion
ces opérations sont dirigées par un
officier système d'armes hautement
qualifiés et un personnel habilité à ce
type d'opération
la formation et l'entraînement des
pilotes passent par le simulateur par
exemple l'instruction que reçoivent les
jeunes stagiaires pilotes et navigateurs
aussi tac le centre d'instruction
tactique de luxeuil les destine aux
unités équipée de mirage 2000 n
au cours de cette formation les
équipages acquièrent les connaissances
de base sur l'emploi du mirage 2000 n de
son système de navigation et d'armement
cette formation est une étape importante
dans la carrière des futurs pilotes et
navigateurs
elle est dispensée par des moniteurs
chevronnés dont la formation s'étale sur
une période de 12 à 24 mois selon le
système étudié
le simulateur à une autre mission c'est
le contrôle des personnels navigants
avec la simulation de panne
la programmation et la conduite de
missions tactiques pouvant aller jusqu'à
de véritables missions de guerre en
ambiance de menaces anti aériennes
particulièrement sévère
régulièrement les pilotes effectuent des
campagnes de tir la base de solenzara en
corse accueille tous les escadrons en
campagne dans ses installations modernes
est particulièrement adaptée à cet
exercice les journées en campagne sont
particulièrement riche en activités et
commence dès le lever du soleil par la
visite journalières dp taf
pendant que les pilotes préparent leur
mission avec une extrême précision
james huth à caen vannes entre nous
taquin tous sachent que le vieux routier
y apprit que quand même en revanche
c'est quand même dès cette es1 on a raté
les inconditionnels à broadway
albert terme hadopi la times daté mis
sur la table
sophie qu'il faut retenir qu'on envoie
les avions sont prêts les boîtes à
munitions des canons de 30 mm sont
remplies les pilotes peuvent prendre les
airs non sans avoir effectué le tour de
l'avion en compagnie de leurs
mécaniciens
dans le grondement des réacteurs les
premiers départs ont lieu sur le parking
qui se vide petit à petit
à tour de rôle les mirage 2000c du 1 12
cambrésis empreinte le taxiway puis
gagne la piste où ils vont pouvoir
découvrir
le jaguar dont le rôle est de tracter la
cible par le premier suivi du décollage
des premiers chasseurs en patrouille
serré
les avions gagne la zone de tir au
dessus de la mer est rapidement la cible
et repérer les pas de tir avons pouvoir
commencer
le tir air est un exercice délicat qui
demande de la pratique et dans lequel il
n'est pas facile d'obtenir de bons
résultats
les passes à vont se succéder toute la
journée pour voir les résultats
s'améliorer franchement
dès que les appareils se posent les
armuriers se dirige vers eux alors
qu'ils se trouvent encore sur le taxiway
afin de mettre en place les sécurités
des armes et de prévenir tout risque
d'accident par le déclenchement
intempestif d'un camion
de retour les équipages sont briefés sur
la séance de tirs sous le contrôle de
leur chef de patrouille
pendant ce temps l'activité ne manquent
pas sur le parking les pètes afro charge
des systèmes d'alimentation des canons
de 30 pendant que se déroule le ballet
des camions citernes du service des
essences des armes
chaque avion englouti trois tonnes de
kérosène par vol de 40 minutes au rythme
de 4 vols par jour et par avion pour une
quinzaine d'avions
ce sont quelques 200 tonnes de kérosène
qui devront être approvisionnés
chaque jour
alors que du côté de la ciblerie le
jaguar couramment appelée le bijoutier
lâche sa cible dans le hurlement des
sirènes avant de se poser les
mécaniciens de l'atelier conditionne de
nouvelles cibles afin de les installer
sous les avions qui vont devoir repartir
aux mains de pilotes
exténué par le rythme et la chaleur
et
ce rythme va continuer jusqu'au
crépuscule pour prendre fin tard dans la
nuit
afin de mettre pleinement à profit ces
campagnes qui malheureusement ne peuvent
pas être répété aussi souvent que le
souhaiteraient les escadrons
la permanence opérationnelle c'est un
petit peu la police du ciel comme on a
des motards sur la route
eh bien on a
la permanence opérationnelle au dessus
du territoire français pour tout ce qui
est espace aérien alors la journée à la
paix au commence normalement à 7 heures
du matin les mécaniciens mon corps est
l'avion le pilote à se préparer et à
cette heure on appelle comment on
conduit des opérations aériennes pour
dire on est prêt et cela jusqu'à
indéterminée mais généralement aux
alentours de 23 heures le soir
oui bonjour c'était pour nous dire que
c'est marc 17 qui passe en sept minutes
alors dès que je suis rentré de mission
les mécaniciens s'affairent autour de
l'avion pour faire le plein repréparer
l'armement et pour rendre l'avion le
plus tôt possible opérationnel pour
qu'un nouveau soit prêt en alerte
c'est à dire qu'en fait en gros en
moyenne on va dire une demi heure à
trois quarts d'heure après que je sois
posé je devrais être prêt à repartir au
camer
avec le deuxième pilote on s'arrange
pour se partager l'alertent donc si on a
à peu près
à peu près 16 heures à faire dans la
journée eh bien on se partage avec
un pilote qui commence le matin ensuite
le deuxième qui le remplace dans la
journée et le pilote du matin qui va
finir la soirée
et ensuite c'est essentiellement de la
tente avec bien sûr qu'ils déjeuners
déjeuners dîners le tout sur place
écoute
l'alerté donnée et nous devons décoller
en moins de sept minutes
donc ça nécessite des contraintes de
mise en oeuvre très courte qui font que
les pilotes sont en permanence équipés
et les avions préparé prêts à décoller
avec les sécurités armements
relever de manière à pois gagner le
maximum de temps possible
c'est une mission comporte
principalement trois volets d'abord le
volet assistance en vol quand on à
l'appareil qui en difficulté peut avoir
une panne
une panne radio ou même des problèmes en
vol ou de navigation a perdu à ce moment
là on intercepte et on essaie de fournir
toute l'assistance ans il a déjà comparé
fait plusieurs fautes
d'une part le rassurer le
réorienter et s'il est en panne radio le
ramener sur un cas pour pouvoir le plus
en foot c'est un deuxième volet
et les mesures de renseignement donc là
c'est
tout d'abord les mesures de
renseignements sur les produits actuels
la nationalité et la conformité des
plans de vols commis des mesures de
renseignements sur des appareils qui
sont en infraction dans des zones
interview donc là on va faire une
identification et on va
si besoin est là
interdire le survol d'une zone et ça
amène au troisième volet qui est
sans les mesures de contrainte là on va
re router un avion ou le dérouter sur un
terrain voire résister retire doucement
un tiers des destructions
le besoin profond
je vais faire un compte rendu de ce qui
s'est passé dans la mission envoyée le
plus tôt possible au centre de conduite
d'opérations aériennes avec
éventuellement si j'ai fait des photos
de l'appareil intercepté préparer ses
photos les conditionner pour les envoyer
via un téléphone crypté aux officiers
anciennement du centre de conduite
roquemaure tu m'as dit que tu allais
intercepté un super étendard
alors c'était à
iv d'après une photo
le mirage 2000 est un avion bien ni les
évolutions constantes que les
constructeurs apporte au fil des années
en font un avion qui connaît un grand
succès à l'exportation en effet de
nombreux pays en ont doté leurs forces
aériennes
parmi eux on trouve la grèce avec 36 mir
a jugé l'un avec quarante deux mirage
2000 e h et l'egypte avec 16 mirage 2000
em
le haut niveau de technologie atteint
tant par les constructeurs aéronautiques
que par les spécialistes de l'armement
fait que le mirage 2000 sera bel et bien
intégré pendant encore de nombreuses
années dans tous les concepts de défense
nationale voire européenne ou mondiale
on